okay so the topic of this video is going
to be how to read a chemical equation
and here is a chemical equation for
photosynthesis and by the end I'm hoping
you will be able to answer these four
questions so as we go through we'll
answer these together let's get started
now as I just mentioned this is the
equation for photosynthesis and in this
chemical equation there are a variety of
elements elements from the periodic
table again what's an element it's a
substance that cannot be chemically
broken down into anything simpler you
can say that elements are the main
components of matter and elements are
determined by their atomic number the
number of protons that they possess for
instance only the element carbon has six
protons in it only the element
oxygen only the element oxygen has eight
total protons
and when we look at this picture here of
the periodic table this is a list of the
known elements and so H for hydrogen
hydrogen is an element
C for carbon carbon is an element over
oxygen oxygen is an element A U for gold
gold is an element none of none of these
elements can be broken down into a
simpler components
so if we come back to this equation
right here my hope is I've just
highlighted question number one I'm
hoping we can scan over and answer
question number one
I hope you've come to the realization
that there are three elements in this
chemical equation
I've just highlighted the c c for carbon
that's one element
I've just highlighted the O's o for
oxygen that's a second element
and I've just highlighted in green the
H's H4 hydrogen that's a third element
so there are three elements in this
entire equation
okay so now let's focus on the equation
in more detail notice there's an arrow
in the middle okay on the left of the
arrow these are what we call the
reactants these are going to be the
molecules that are going to be input
into photosynthesis so on the left of
the arrow these are the reactants
on the right of the arrow this is what
are called the products these are what's
going to be produced these are the
outputs another way to look at it the
left of the arrow is kind of like the
before and the right of the arrow is
kind of like the after
and so let's actually look at this a
little more closely
CO2 CO2 you might know is a molecule
that's one molecule of carbon dioxide
but notice how there is a 6 in front of
the CO2 what that tells me is that that
grouping right there is actually six
molecules of carbon dioxide
let's look at the H2O
water H2O is one molecule of water but
notice there's a six in front that tells
me that little grouping there is six
molecules of water
let's look at the O2 on the right hand
side of the arrow
O2 that's one molecule of atmospheric
oxygen
but the 6 right there tells me that
there are six molecules of oxygen in
this equation
and now look at the final part the
C6H12O6 that right there is one molecule
of glucose notice how there's no number
before so that just means it's one
molecule of glucose
so now I'm hoping you can answer
questions two and three for question
number two how many total molecules can
be seen in this equation
just add them up right there add up the
six plus the six plus the six plus the
one and you come to 19 molecules
for question number three if we're just
looking at the product molecules add up
the six molecules of oxygen plus the one
molecule of glucose and you have an
answer of seven molecules
okay now for number four
when we focus our attention on the atoms
carbon dioxide we just mentioned carbon
dioxide is one molecule however it's one
molecule made from three atoms it's made
from one carbon atom and it's also made
from two oxygen atoms so there's a total
of three atoms in carbon dioxide
but again there's the six in front so
there's six molecules and every molecule
is three atoms in size six times three
is 18. 6 CO2 combines for 18 atoms
let's look at the water
water is another molecule made from
three atoms it's made from two hydrogen
atoms and also one oxygen atom but look
at the six in front again there are six
total molecules and every molecule is
made from three atoms so six times three
that grouping right there is a total of
18 atoms My Hope Is that you can do the
others
and then come to the answer of question
number four
so I'm going to pause uh pause the video
and try to complete the rest I'm going
to go over the answers in three two one
so I hope you came up with 72 atoms and
if and if you're not quite sure then
let's talk out the rest
O2 O2 is made from two atoms it's a
small molecule it's only made from two
atoms
two oxygen atoms to be specific and then
the six in front six total molecules and
every molecule is made from two atoms so
six times twelve or six times two excuse
me six times two is twelve atoms
and then when we look at the glucose the
C6H12O6 you can see that there are 24
atoms in that one molecule there are six
carbon atoms and there are also 12
hydrogen atoms and there are also six
oxygen atoms so that adds up to 24 total
atoms
and so that's how we got the 72 atoms
just add up the 18 plus 18 plus 12 plus
24 for 72 atoms
now what you also might notice is that
there's 36 atoms on the left of the
arrow 36 atoms of the reactants and
there's also 36 atoms in the products
that's not a coincidence you are always
going to see the amount of reactant
atoms equal to the amount of product
atoms this is because of the law of
conservation of matter which states that
matter cannot be created nor destroyed
but it can change forms so the atoms of
the reactants changed forms they changed
forms from carbon dioxide and water they
changed forms into oxygen and glucose
that's what happens during
photosynthesis is the molecules that are
involved change forms
wrap this up by again reading the
equation this is how you would uh you
know like how you would read it is you
would say six molecules of carbon
dioxide
and six molecules of water
will yield or will react to make
six molecules of oxygen
and one molecule of glucose and so
that's how you would read the chemical
equation in this case of photosynthesis
other examples are performed in the
exact same way I hope you found this
video helpful thanks for watching